We live in a world that is increasingly globalized,
where cultures and traditions are melding together
at an unprecedented pace.
While this can be a great thing,
it also means that we must be vigilant in preserving
and celebrating the unique identities
and traditions that make each culture special.
As pageant contestants,
we have a unique opportunity to use our platform
and our voice to advocate for cultural diversity
and inclusivity.
We can use our influence to promote
understanding and appreciation for different cultures
and to break down the barriers that separate us.
I believe that cultural diversity and inclusivity
are essential for creating a better world.
By embracing and celebrating our differences,
we can learn from each other
and grow together as a global community.
We can build bridges of understanding and compassion
and create a world where everyone is
valued and respected.
So today, I urge you to join me in
advocating for cultural diversity and inclusivity.
Let us use our voices to promote understanding,
to celebrate our differences,
and to create a more compassionate
and inclusive world for all. Thank you.